I don't believe that we can necessarily
convinced racists through through reason
or through shame I think we have to
crush them politically being woke too
often these days is just a matter of
turning and doing high-fives with people
who think like you and not being
concerned with doing the work and
thinking about what really helps people
continue to have a society that is
divided and unequal in racist in racial
terms and those inherited racial
inequalities do come from a deep past
that we have never properly reckoned
with in public policy or in our public
history virtue signaling now stands in
for being politically concerned a person
who in 1965 would have said what can I
do to help is now asking how can I show
that I'm a moral person but that's more
Martin Luther than Martin Luther King I
just made that up just now they're
welcome to this fifth to this third
debate rather of the third season of the
civil forum at the subculture Theatre in
downtown Manhattan I'm Jean Epstein
director of the solo forum tonight's
resolution reads the message of anti
racism has become as harmful a force in
American life as racism itself we do
Oxford style voting as most of you know
we the initial vote is the baseline and
whoever moves the vote in his or her
favor wins technically wins the debate
well while you're thinking about that
resolution I just want to thank you all
thank those of you who who attended our
big gala socials and debate at the John
Jay theatre we did get nearly 500 people
to show up many of them socialists and
so we were very pleased by that we
needed in other words a much larger
place to accommodate that
crowd it was a debate that I
participated in taking the negative
technically I did win and I want to
thank all of you who who complimented me
on how it went
the it's been 21 days since the reason
released the YouTube video and we've had
28 thousand views of that video which is
the second highest we've ever had the
third highest was 16,000 in our debate
and education the first is our absolute
outlier the highest of all was 355
thousand views for a Bitcoin debate
Bitcoin debates clearly attract a lot of
people but we did certainly did well on
our socials and debate I had four
separate invitations to appear on
podcast to be interviewed about the
debate I did make for those of you who
haven't seen it I did make the novel
argument that socialists do not have to
abolish capitalism in order to achieve a
socialist economy it's actually quite is
a pedestrian argument obviously enough
obvious enough but rather novel
certainly from the standpoint of my
debating opponent bhaskar sankara I do
want to take to it to heart two
criticisms that I received about the way
the debate went on the one hand a few
days after I did the debate I went to a
conference and a bunch of young guys
surrounded me they'd been there and they
told me you are on fire you killed it
you crushed it I almost felt sorry for
the guy
and that was good to hear but then I did
say well guys it's probably a mistake to
make people feel sorry for your debater
the debating opponent maybe I was a
little bit too much on fire and killed
it a little bit too much and so I do
take to heart those critics who said you
lost it a little bit I guarantee you
that I wasn't doing this in any tactical
or conscious way I think in a way I was
hectoring my younger self when I
started yelling at Pascoe Sankara that
he should read up on economics and
possibly appreciate the point that it
can make the revolution right now but I
promise you that I'll do try to do
better the next time and recognize that
it doesn't pay to to lose it to some
degree as I did also I mean the other
criticism was that maybe I was stepping
into the debating ring so to speak with
a with a lightweight
he's only 29 I mean does he is indeed
the editor-in-chief of Jacobin magazine
he's got a book contract with basic
books a very prestigious labor label he
is going places but I'm now in talks
with a guy named Richard Wolfe who's in
his 70s I'm an emeritus professor UMass
publisher of many books on the
importance of socialism and possibly
next October
only every October who we do outreach to
socialist I'm gonna have another debate
on socialism with in this case a Richard
Wolff I also want to announce that what
you see or so on your on your chair was
is the 50th anniversary edition of
Reason magazine I've read it
cover-to-cover it really is a delight
and a collector's item I know is if
nygma Nichol ESPYs in the house Nick you
want to come to the stage for a moment
and talk about it or you're not in the
mood
Nick Nick would rather not you're
welcome okay Ted take a copy and read it
Nick has a fine article in it about the
Whole Earth Catalog some of you are old
enough to remember it I certainly am
publish it at the same time that reason
was it's got a rollicking article about
Lanny Friedlander the slightly loony guy
who started reason 50 years ago and some
somebody put me up short recently and
said well why else is it called reason
it's called reason because it was
created by by an Objectivist anion Randy
and as indeed it was it's it's gone a
bit eclectic since then in terms of the
Aisne random thews yes but Lanny
Friedlander definitely did call it
reason in in the spirit of iron ran
anyway I do recommend that you take it
home and once you finish it give it to
your socialist friends to read as well
now I'm at also forums we do want to
have our warm-up act that is Dave Smith
who puts out the show part of the
problem Dave I hope you're in the
audience and I hope you can come to the
stage to teach us how not to be part of
the problem forum without all those
commie bastards this is a that was fun
but you know I'm over it at this point
of any of you people heckle me I'm fist
fighting you outside after this I that
was a fun one congratulations gene on
your dominant performance welcome back
Jane everybody just had a baby is back
with us today so if you're at yeah clap
you animals gonna cave in I'm really
just saying because my wife is
eight-and-a-half months pregnant and I
want you guys to clap for me when I come
back after that but yeah she could go
any time now but I as I told people in
the back if she if she look like calls
me and says my water just broke
I'm not leaving the debate I'm just like
sorry this isn't a good time for me so I
don't know what to tell you it is hard
it's hard being like married when your
wife's pregnant it's like a weird time
because it's so much that they go
through and you're just kind of there
you know right gently it's like it's
kind of like you're like a Yankee fan
and she's Derek Jeter and you're just
the person who did this to Derek Jeter
and every now and then you're like can I
get you another pillow Derek Jeter and
then you're like why is Derek Jeter
furious at me right now I don't know but
it's alright sorry the topic at hand
racism personally I'm against it but
let's have the debate and see what
happens I don't know I host I'm I am
against racism because you know I'm a
Jew and of course I don't want anyone to
hate blacks because if you hate black
people you also hate Jews those are the
rules
alright there's never been anybody who
hated black people and didn't also hate
Jews right
there's never like a guy who's like you
know the problem is these blacks and
you're like what do you think of the
Jews and they're like good people
nothing against that like we're always
dragged into that [ __ ] too
so just for self you know I don't think
racism is really that big of a problem
today I mean I have it on good authority
that Donald Trump is going to do
tremendously great things for the black
community so yeah Donald Trump said that
himself so you know it's true you hear
Donald Trump said and this is a direct
quote he said that in his re-election
campaign in 2020 he is gonna carry
ninety-five percent of the black vote it
was actually the most modest thing
Donald Trump has ever said she
acknowledged five percent might still go
the other way but do you remember back
it up in 2016 when Donald Trump said his
pitch to the black voters was what do
you have to lose do you remember that
when he was just like you're living in
squalor like what do you have to lose
vote Trump that was the greatest pitch
I've ever heard in my life a politician
man and my white liberal friends were so
outraged like they were so that's the
most racist thing ever they have nothing
to lose and then I talked to one of my
black friends and he was like makes a
pretty good point like you know it's
this [ __ ] might work after all I don't
know racism isn't isn't good sometimes
it works out I was one time I was uh
this is like ten years ago and I was in
Toronto with another friend of mine a
comedian and we were on traveling doing
shows in Toronto and you know I was
young I was in my 20s and so was he and
he was like hey you know it'd be fun on
this trip is if we got some weed and I
was like I agree sir because we spoke
proper English back then and um
and he goes uh he was like we should try
to find some weed and then my friend
just and he goes uh he was like I'm
gonna ask that big black bouncer outside
the strip club if he knows where we can
get weed and I was like whoa dude that's
a little racist but in Justin's defense
not
only did that guy know he was selling
weed so we ended up buying weed from
that guy worked that well that time I'm
just saying it wasn't cool but it did
work out pretty pretty effectively at
that point but it was yeah my friend
doesn't just like charge right up to him
and I was like I don't think we should
do this and he was like hey bro and I
was like don't call him bro like what
and he was like you know where I can get
some weed and this bit he was like big
black dude you know bouncer and he was
he goes uh he goes are you guys cops and
I was like no we're not cops we're
comedians were performing down the
street and then he just like I didn't
say it he goes are you guys cops I was
like now I just said we're not cops and
he goes you guys are cops right and I
was like we should just leave this isn't
gonna work out well and then I said no
one more time and then just pulled out a
huge bag of weed in the middle of the
street the middle of the Toronto Strait
and I was like it's three times the
charm now that's all
like if we were real cops the third time
would have gotta you know what you cops
now know and they're like you're cops
yep ah you got man a cop all right get
out of here
but anyway wherever that guy is in the
world thanks for getting me weed ten
years ago appreciate that so I do you
know I wouldn't call myself an expert in
black culture but I did I got a haircut
at a black barbershop once in my life it
was an accident
but it happened and another story this
is the life of a comedian I was always
on the road and I was in like I don't
remember where I think it was Memphis or
something but I needed a haircut and
there was just a sign that said
barbershop and I didn't know what it was
it was like in this mall and and I
walked in and then I realized it was a
black barbershop like as I got in there
but it was too late
because I was already there and there
was like this is this big jacked-up
black dude wearing a wife-beater and
like a huge gold chain and he I walked
in and the conversation that I literally
I interrupted he was talking to a friend
of his and he was like so I told that
[ __ ]
I'll kill you and then he looked over
who's like can I help you I was right
Oh what did I just get myself into I was
like I think I'm just gonna take off and
then he just like black guy bullied me
into getting a haircut the [ __ ] bro and
I sat down and he was like who's like so
what do you want and you know I was like
I don't know and just take a little off
the top and then he said the most
terrifying words that my white ears have
ever heard in my life before a haircut
which is he goes so you want like a
scissor haircut and I was like this
isn't gonna work out Wow and it didn't
it did not work out well at all he
pulled out a pair of scissors that look
like they came with the barbershop when
they open LaBarbara shot like no one's
ever used these here before and he was
like it was like he was just guessing
like you're just like I don't know but I
was like thank you and and I left but
that's all I got that's my experience
with black culture I'm sorry no no I'm
just kidding I grew up in Brooklyn
there's every race of culture that's
what racism never even seemed like a
real thing to me but I guess it is a
real thing like every now and then
that's like the thing like you learn as
like cuz I'm a Jewish kid from Brooklyn
so it's not like people are really like
it's all just like a joke to me the idea
of like open bigotry but then when I
started going throughout the country
you're like there's a little bit of it
out there right I used to always think
it was crazy it was just something
left-wing people made up like there's no
there's no racism in this country and
then it's kind of it's been brought up
to the surface a little bit in the last
few years you know like I like the
left-wing people would always call like
Trump supporters Nazis so you're like
there's no Nazis you know and then they
had that charlottesville thing and I was
like there might be a few there might be
a couple of a mouth
I don't know either like they're not
Nazis they're just conservatives you
know it's like that guy's got a swastika
tattoo on his neck and you're like okay
he's on the edge like that guy might be
a little bit but I still just laugh at
it I don't know why I just laugh at like
even in that in the Charlottesville
thing when they were chanting the Jews
will not replace us at like I'm a Jew
I've that was the most empowered I've
ever felt as a Jewish person in my
entire life they're out there like the
Jews will not replace it like look I
have never in my wildest Jew fantasies
entertained the idea of replacing
anybody we simply don't have the numbers
but then you saw all these [ __ ] angry
tiki torch guys and they're like the
Jews will not replace us and I was like
you know what I think we can replace
these [ __ ] right I think we can
do this we just get our act together
let's strike now Jews time all right you
guys are great enjoyed the debate
everybody thank you for having me thank
you gene Dave Smith and you should
listen to his part of the problem
podcast he's he's terrific well now for
the main event
remember the resolution reads the
message of anti racism has become as
harmful of force in American life as
racism itself here to speak for the
affirmative Columbia University
professor John McWhorter John please
come to the stage
and speaking for the negative and why
you professor
Nikhil Singh Nikhil please come to the
stage Jane please close the voting so
closed okay
John now please take the podium and
speak for the affirmative thank you
let's talk about the cops is very
important I think when we discuss racism
in America and whether it exists in to
what extent and how important it is the
first thing on a lot of our minds is
racism from the police and so I think we
need to talk about that first and
there's some things that I don't think
we always know Tamir rice was a black
boy of about 12 who was brandishing a
toy weapon and he was shot dead the
exact same thing happened to a boy named
Daniel shaver not long after that Daniel
shaver was white Sam DuBose was shot
dead by the police driving his car away
from a cop the exact same thing happened
actually a little bit before that to a
white guy named Andrew Thomas
Alton Stirling was a black man who
reached into his waistband and reached
for his wallet during an altercation
with the cops and the cops shot him dead
that was a grievous event and the same
thing actually happened around the same
time to a white guy named Dylan Noble
Alton sterling made national headlines
none of us heard about Dylan Noble
George Zimmerman said some really nasty
things about unspecified little people
and how they're always going around
stealing things before he ended up
killing Trayvon Martin now that was a
terrible thing especially because
policeman said the same sorts of things
including using the word [ __ ] before
he killed a white teenager named Lauren
Simpson I could do this for 20 minutes
there is a very understandable tendency
in the media to report stories of black
people unjustly killed by the police
whereas what we don't know is that for
every one of those events there is a
white teenager or twenty-something who
is killed under almost ominously similar
conditions where you've really got to
dig to find it out now I'm not saying
that there's fake news or some grand
conspiracy I understand why the media
are so concerned with the black cases
but I'm bringing this up because I think
that generally we are often told that
any conversation about race is shut down
by the purported racist tendencies of
cops who in a hair-trigger situation
will allow their quiet bias to kill a
black guy when if it were a white guy he
would get away with a slap on the hand
that's a very reasonable assumption but
you know that really hasn't held up to
scrutiny that's why I allowed myself to
do this particular debate with this
particular question even the numbers are
quite different from what we hear and so
for example there is the issue of
proportion so white men 62% of the male
population they are half of the people
who get killed by cops
black men 13% and they are a quarter of
the people who are killed by cops and so
it's disproportionate so one might think
well that means that still there is a
racist bias against black men because so
many more them are killed
proportionately but no not really
there's a debate team trick that's going
on in relation to that because it wasn't
so long ago that when we talked about
welfare disproportionate amount of black
people were on welfare but more white
people were on welfare and numerically
so if anybody pointed out that a
disproportionate number of black people
were on wealth
it was always pointed out by a certain
crowd that no actually many more white
people are on welfare and that was
considered a Smackdown comment well
we're in the same sort of situation or
it was often said if you kept asking
questions the reason there's a
disproportionate number of black people
on welfare is because poverty affects
black people disproportionately because
of structural racism that was reasonable
well we also know that poverty makes it
more likely for somebody to encounter a
policeman in these sorts of situations
poverty caused by structural racism
therefore might certainly make it so
that there are more black men killed by
the police and that means that we have
to question the idea that what this is
all about is underlying pernicious
biases of the cops I almost can't
believe I'm saying this because I spent
a very long time thinking what a lot of
people think about the cops I have a
reputation for saying that racism is
there as important as people make it but
I always made an exception for the cops
and not too long ago I had one of my
blogging heads conversations with Glenn
Lowry where I told him Glenn you've got
to give me figures if that's not true
and I didn't know that the figures
actually exist and so I had to really
make an adjustment really think in a new
way about this kind of thing what we're
told about the cops simply isn't true
therefore when I say that anti racism is
as much a problem as a help at this
point on saying that after my conversion
about the cops the cops are not a
Smackdown issue in this in this debate
so with that said what's the issue here
why in the world would I say that anti
racism is a problem because of course no
it's not a problem to not be a racist
and I don't think any of us would be
here if we thought the debate was over
that so of course you don't want to be a
racist racism is bad we know that but
what about the more complex and
therefore more interesting issues and
one issue is that anti racism as
currently configured has gone a long way
from what used to be considered
intelligent and sincere civil rights
activism today it's a religion and I
don't mean
as a rhetorical feint I mean that it
actually is what any naive
anthropologist would recognize as a
faith in people many of whom don't think
of themselves as religious but Galileo
would recognize them quite easily and so
for example the idea that the
responsible white person is supposed to
attest to their white privilege and
realize that it can never go away and
feel eternally guilty about it that's
original sin right there
the idea that there is going to be a day
when America comes to terms with race or
that there could be what does that even
mean what is the meaning of the coming
to terms what would that consist of who
would come to them what would the terms
be at what date would this be the only
reason that anybody says that is because
it corresponds to our conception of
Judgment Day and it's equally abstract
when we use the word problematic
especially since about two thousand
eight or nine what we're really saying
is blasphemous it's really the exact
same term or the suspension of disbelief
that is a characteristic of religious
faith there's an extent to which logic
is considered no longer to apply that's
how we talk about racism and so suppose
someone asked why are we to focus on the
occasional rogue cop who kills a black
man when nine times out of ten that
black man is in much more danger of
being killed by another black man in his
neighborhood gosh that's not pretty but
like many things that aren't pretty it's
also true if you ask about it well you
know you're not supposed to eyes roll
and you're given an answer that doesn't
really completely make sense and there's
an etiquette that you're supposed to
stop there it's rather like certain
questions that you ask a priest very
gently but you know that if you don't
get a real answer then you're just
supposed to move on that we're used to
with being devoutly religious that is
the way racism is treated these days
it's a religion and many of us might say
you know after thinking about it you
might realize that even if you're
somebody who looks on devout religious
faith amongst a
a Mormon or fundamentalist as something
peculiar you read books by
anthropologists exploring this frame of
mind even if you realize it might even
be pleasant to realize about yourself
that you are religious just like them if
you wonder how a Mormon feels to be an
anti-racist today is to be ideologically
a very very similar person you might own
it you might say what's wrong with this
what's wrong with this religion this is
certainly a better religion than many
others I can think of but there are
problems with it there's severe problems
with it it does some good things it gets
some good people elected certainly it
does some good things but it does some
bad things and so for example if you're
a good anti-racist then you're thinking
about the cops that kill black men in
these scenes that we know about but
you're not supposed to think about the
fact that so much more murder happens to
men like that in their own neighborhoods
you're supposed to think of that as may
be connected to racism in some abstract
way but you're not supposed to think
about it you're not supposed to think
about all of those homicides every
summer in big cities across America
teenage black boys are killing one
another in the hundreds over frankly
nothing that's somehow less important
than what the occasional rogue cop does
that's modern anti racism for you that's
backwards
another example education to be an
anti-racist is to pay attention to the
idea that universities must foster
diversity the idea being that supposedly
universities wouldn't want to foster
this diversity if they weren't made to
do so now what that means is that often
this diversity is fostered as the result
of creating a different evaluation
system for black and often Latino
students in terms of grades and test
scores now there are various studies
that show that that often is not the
best thing and so Stephen Cole and
Eleanor barber did a paper where
contrary to their expectations that
showed that when students are mismatched
to a university it discourages them from
getting PhDs there have been many
studies of that kind but we're told to
look a
away from them so after racial
preferences were banned in the
University of California before they
were banned at the University of
California San Diego in a freshman class
of 3268 students of the freshman honor
students exactly one was black in 1999
this is the first class admitted after
the ban when students were matched to a
school according to their grades and
test scores rather than their being the
kind of bonus that we see we're now
seeing it at Harvard one out of five
black freshmen were making honors why
have you never heard of that statistic
it's actually a beautiful story
these are black students who did very
well who wouldn't have done as well at
Berkeley or UCLA
there's no tragedy those students are
now out working and living wonderful
lives anti racism teaches us not to
listen to stories like those and when we
think about anti racism we're taught to
suppose we start to not even think about
this anymore that whites need to undergo
some sort of massive psychological
revolution before we can have any kind
of black success beyond what we have
already why why is somebody talking
about their white privilege important
when we're talking about making black
schools better why is it important for a
black lives matter activists to probe
Hillary Clinton's heart as opposed to
thinking about what policy she will take
in terms of criminal sentencing or
housing policy or the on-the-ground
sorts of things that we really need to
be thinking about if we want to help
black people I could go on here too
there are a lot of things wrong with
anti racism there are some good things
but they're just as many that are wrong
that hold us back from helping black
people who need help because we're
taught to think of certain things rather
than other things in particular we're
taught to think less about the real work
of helping people who need help on the
ground through socio-political action
and instead when we end up thinking
about inner psychology we end up
thinking about that which is problematic
and all of these things are ultimately
idle so this is what I mean by saying
that anti racism
is a problem anti-racism is currently
configured not anti-racism just in
itself but modern anti-racism turns a
blind eye to most black homicide
anti-racism as currently configured
turns a blind eye to black young
people's upward mobility it turns a
blind eye to doing the kinds of things
that civil rights leaders of 50 years
ago considered ordinary in favor of what
is ultimately an inward lis focused
quest for moral absolution that has at
best a diagonal relationship to helping
people who've been left behind for that
reason the issue here I must repeat is
not whether or not racism exists we know
it does read the paper this morning had
some racism of my own two weeks ago
that's not the issue the issue is
whether modern anti racism is the best
way of combating the effects of that
racism and it isn't thank you
Mikhail's sing for the negative tell you
the way to kill I was told that John is
a formidable debater and I am NOT going
to be as capable of talking to you
without notes but I do want to remind
you of the proposition before us which
is not exactly as it was just framed the
message of anti racism has become as
harmful of force in American life as
racism itself and that is the
proposition I will speak to and I want
you to remember those four words as
harmful as racism itself so the claim of
anti racism as harm here depends on how
we assess the harm of racism and racial
discrimination today what I'll attempt
to persuade you of in my time is a that
racism remains a harmful force in our
social economic and political life in
ways that we actually can't just take
for granted and be that the tangible
harms of racism overwhelm any case that
might be made for the annoyances or
inconveniences produced by certain
expressions of anti racism so I want to
begin with a set of facts that I do not
think are in dispute about racial
disparity John also spoke to issues of
racial disparity in his comments I'm
sure we'll come back to this the United
States in 2018 is characterized by
racial disparities across every
significant indicator of life chances
wealth homeownership rates of
unemployment poverty arrest and
incarceration in some cases the
statistical disparities are staggering
black and Latino families have between
eight and ten cents to every dollar of
wealth owned by white families now in an
audience like this I'm well aware that
claiming evident disparity is not
adequate and will not be taken as proof
of racial discrimination three examples
from well-respected researchers might
begin to test the
question in her seminal work dr. dev a
beggar who was Peter and Isabel Malkin
professor of public policy at the
Kennedy School of Government at Harvard
and professor of sociology at the
University before her recent untimely
death documented what she called the
powerful effects of race on hiring
decisions employers she found were more
likely to hire a white man even if he
had a felony conviction than a black man
with no criminal record blacks who said
they had a criminal record had a
callback rate of 5% and blacks who said
they did not had a rate of 14% for
whites the rates were 17% for those who
said they had a criminal record and 34%
for those who said they did not a new
paper from three respected economists
with over 400,000 data points over 50
metro areas shows that african-americans
pay more for identical housing in
identical neighborhoods than their white
counterparts and that this rent gap
increases with the fraction of the
neighborhood and its racial percentages
so the more white it gets the higher the
premium goes for black entering that
neighborhood similar studies have been
done on residential steering practices
in the real estate industry and the
differential cost of insurance mortgage
rates and so on paid by economically
similar black and non black applicants
now a potential limitation of any racial
disparity comparisons is that they are
sometimes not apples to apples for
example we know that not having a high
school degree is actually the greatest
predictor of whether one ends up
involved in the criminal justice system
nevertheless even among high school
dropouts four out of ten African
American males end up in prison compared
to one in ten of their white
counterparts
the ACLU found that African Americans
are four times more likely to be
arrested for marijuana possession than
whites even though their rate of
marijuana usage was comparable in New
York City alone there are over 5 million
stops and frisks between 2002 and 2012
85% of those stopped were black and
Latino leading to the legal challenge
that found the practice racially
discriminatory
and unconstitutional so let me stop here
I may not have convinced you that we
continue to live in a society in which
racial discrimination leading to unequal
life chances is a problem though I hope
I have at least dented the automatic
presumption that some may have that this
is not true I want to turn to a second
area in which I think we can see how
racism both as a message and a practice
remains harmful with respect to our
political life and the health of our
democracy let's call this the
contemporary force of political racism
once again we are all likely familiar
with the fact that political racism has
been a part of US history from its
inception including the defense of
slavery overseas expansion Jim Crow
segregation and now white nationalism
political racism has been a tool to
divide the electorate and to suppress
participation in democratic politics we
can locate its real origins in the
aftermath of the Civil War and
reconstruction and the organized and
systematic effort to suppress black
men's ability to exercise the franchise
through a variety of legal and
extralegal means including literacy
tests poll taxes police intimidation and
vigilante violence up to and including
lynching like the question of racial
disparity you might say even if we
accept the full scope of this kind of
racism it was in the past it is no
longer characteristic of our political
present in 1965 the United States
finally fulfilled its promise by
becoming a liberal democracy for the
first time in its history with the
passage of the civil rights and voting
rights acts we've been a liberal
democracy for a short 50 years then and
notwithstanding the fact that we were a
racial democracy and a racist democracy
for almost two centuries prior we can
rest assured that the racist past is
behind us at least this was the view of
the US Supreme Court which in 2013 in
Shelby versus holder lifted the
provisions of the Voting Rights Act that
had required states with long histories
of suppressing black voting rights to
get federal approval to change any
voting laws lo and behold after she
24 states implemented new restrictions
on voting Texas Alabama now require
photo IDs to cast a ballot other states
such as Ohio and Georgia have enacted
use-it-or-lose-it laws which strike
voters from the registration rolls if
they have not participated in an
election within a prescribed period of
time let's just look at one state where
this dynamic has unfolded the still
contested race for governor in the state
of Georgia an election characterized by
red baiting and race baiting of the
black candidate Stacey Abrams who
president Trump described as unqualified
for office even though she graduated
from the same law school as Brett
Kavanaugh setting Trump's words aside
the election process has been overseen
by Abraham's opponent Brian Kemp who has
been the secretary of state of the state
of Georgia for the past eight years and
refused to recuse himself even though he
was a party to the election that he was
overseeing during his time as Secretary
of State
Kemp aggressively purged one and a half
million people almost 10 percent of all
people on the voting rolls he closed
more than 214 polling places he
criminally prosecuted people on
trumped-up charges of voter fraud in the
run-up to the election he blocked 53,000
voter registrations in the state 70%
from African Americans 80% from people
of color which is close to the margin in
his current lead and he oversaw the
delivery of voting machines without
power cords to three predominantly
African American counties US federal
court ruled yesterday that Gwinnett
County's mass rejection of absentee
ballots based on an omitted or incorrect
birth year violates the Civil Rights Act
the county is more than 50% African
American and Latino more damning almost
all of Kemp's maneuvers striking people
from the rolls for not having an exact
match that is where the name on the
voter rolls is identical to the name in
the state system was actually disallowed
under the Voting Rights Act as
discriminatory against minority voters
when Georgia tried to implement it in
2009 Georgia of course is not alone in
these high-tech Jim Crow shenanigans and
we can discuss other
examples later I wager that it is
difficult to find a similar analog such
as anti-racist voter suppression most
anti-racist I know are struggling to
increase Democratic participation and
widen the use of the franchise where
they are trying to contest elections but
I realize that this issue is now infused
with partisanship you hear it in my
voice and my account might not yet have
convinced you that racism remains
harmful in ways that Dwarfs any concern
we might have about anti-racist excesses
so let me turn to my third and final set
of examples the harmfulness of racially
motivated and racist violence in the
current moment on June 17th 2015
just just a few months before the
election of Donald Trump as US president
Dylan roof entered the Emanuel African
Methodist Episcopal all
african-americans including senior
pastor at state senator clementa pickney
on social media Ruth posed with symbols
of white supremacy and neo-nazism
along with a manifesto in which he
outlined derogatory views towards blacks
among other people just two weeks ago
another white man tried to enter the
First Baptist Church in Jeffersontown
Kentucky finding the door locked he
entered Kroger's grocery store and
murder two black women calling upon
coming upon a white patron Heda mirrored
uttering the sentence white doesn't kill
white just over a week later another
white man shouting anti-semitic slurs
entered a synagogue in Pittsburgh and
Massacre twelve congregants four months
prior he had spewed hate memes on
right-wing social media that Jews were
the enemy of white people the synagogue
shooter was apparently particularly
incensed by the immigrant and refugee
support work done by the Tree of Life
congregation and of course the most
recent actions occurred against a
backdrop of an election that Trump
consistently depicted as a brown
invasion at the southern border and that
his vice president Pence added was
likely infiltrated by Islamic militants
just this past Monday an attorney
representing Patrick Stein one of three
men convicted
convicted of plotting to bomb Somali
refugees filed memo in US District Court
in Kansas Stein his lawyer argued should
receive a more lenient sentence because
he was inspired by then candidate Donald
Trump are these than just outliers the
anti-defamation league Center on
extremism has reported that 71% of
extremist related fatalities in the
United States between 2008 and 2017 were
committed by members of the far-right or
white supremacist movements reported
hate crimes in America rose 17% last
year the third consecutive year that
such crimes increased according to newly
released FBI data that showed an even
larger increase in anti-semitic attacks
in conclusion let me make a couple of
points both sides do it is often the
afraid the refrain and both sides ISM is
unfortunately built into the structure
of what is in question here anti racism
and racism are equally harmful and let
us not forget after charlottesville as
funny as our opening act was when white
supremacists chanted jews will not
replace us and murder to counter
protester this was Trump's argument when
he insisted that there are good and bad
people on both sides but I see little to
no real evidence that anti racism or
anti-racists have his yet participated
in anything on the order of the kinds of
Democratic voter suppression or racially
motivated violence that we are seeing in
the current moment the last thing I want
to say not only is racism harmful it
makes us stupid even before Trump took
office his presidential transition team
began drawing up plans to redirect
national security resources away from
white supremacist to focus solely on
Islamic terrorism which has been three
times less significant in terms of the
fatalities that has produced in this
period than white supremacists or
right-wing terror the main target of
this effort was countering violent
extremism an interagency task force
created by Barack Obama in the wake of
the Charleston Church shooting to help
prevent acts of violence before they
happen perhaps the worst that can be
said about anti racism is that it is
ineffective based mostly on che
racists in the face of structural
political and over polls in face of
structural racism political racism and
overt racist violence empty moralism
will not do not only do we need to do
more as a society to overcome historic
racist inequalities or racism historic
inequalities but we need to stop
rewarding or whitewashing political
racism and we need to prevent prosecute
and punish racist violence
none of this suggests that anti racism
is really the problem if anything is
true we need a more capacious and
inclusive and effective anti racism that
draws upon the legacies of our better
history thank you rebuttal from John
recorded Thank You Nikhil you're quite
right that racism exists and it's a
problem and these violent events are
absolutely important attestation of it
but I'm not sure that I agree that anti
racism is just a kind of fashion
statement nipping at heels I may not
have made myself clear here's another
example so poverty makes boys in
particular more likely to act up that's
a fact that's been shown in countless
studies now often in especially public
schools across the country black boys
are disciplined more than white boys now
one reason that the black boys might be
acting up more is because of the effects
of poverty and that is something that
needs to be addressed by concrete action
rather than people putting their hand in
the air and saying that they attest to
their white privilege but instead what
we often see is claims especially from
certain academic departments that the
only reason that black boys could be
censored or suspended more would be
racist bias and if you look at all the
studies on this they basically just come
down to a draw in this city starting in
2015 mayor de Blasio spearheaded
effort to have black boys disciplined
less in our hardest inner-city schools
with the highest proportions of black
kids that's good anti racism but the
problem is that over the past three
years in all of those schools where
people have so many problems already
this is right here in this city and it's
not only here at similar stories in
Philadelphia you have more alcohol use
more drug use more violence and more
gang activity keeping these poor kids
who are you know often black all of them
from getting a good education all out of
a sense that it's racist to discipline
black boys who are keeping the vast
majority of students in the school from
learning that's not a fashion statement
nipping at the heels that's a real
problem
violence is a horrible thing when
somebody like Dylan roof pulls what he
did Charlottesville
was not a joke those things are
definitely happening but there are two
things going on here they're those
isolated events where Grievous things
happen to perfectly innocent people then
there's an issue of lifting the black
race up in general and solving general
disparities and we often tend to think
that that's practically impossible when
really a lot of the problem is the
things that were encouraged to focus on
are based much more on the idea that our
main focus is supposed to be making sure
that we're not discriminating against
black people rather than actually
helping black people and something else
a little example of that voting what the
Republicans are doing in terms of trying
to suppress the black vote is obvious
and it's one of the most revolting
things I have ever seen it's it's a
horrible effort however there's
something that you're not supposed to
say and I'm gonna say it there is a
difference between the motivation for
that now and the motivation for what was
going on during Jim Crow and before and
we all know it what the Republicans are
doing is disgusting and it's racist in
terms of the definition that we use
today it hurts
black people and it devalues black
well certainly but having just come from
making my way through that new Fredrick
Douglas biography that we're reading
about and hoping we might get through
you could hurt your foot if you dropped
it on you but I actually read it all the
way through the reason that they didn't
want black people to vote then was
because they thought black people were
animals my grandparents had trouble
voting in cities like Atlanta not
because Republicans didn't want to have
Democrats have too many votes and they
thought that it would be a canny thing
to go for the group that votes for
Democrats so consistently that's cynical
and disgusting in itself but the reason
was because they thought that people of
my grandparents generation or animals so
there's kind of a difference yes what's
going on with voting is a serious
problem but if we're talking about what
racism is frankly the way I feel is that
Americans tend to treat black America
and to convince black America that this
is true that we are the weakest most
Thekla hothouse flowers in the 300,000
year history of the human species and
that that is how we should have Policy
approached I just don't believe it and I
think that it is a serious problem we
could be doing better on civil rights
now than we are
I mean first of all I can't couldn't
agree more with the last statement that
we could be doing better on civil rights
than we are
I also think I made the case and
probably could make it if I had more
time in more detail that when we look at
the upsurge of white supremacist
violence in the United States we are not
actually talking about a few isolated
incidents we are actually talking about
the movement of something that may once
have been fringe or maybe once was
forbidden and then became fringe into
the into quite mainstream political
discourse and when you see the president
retweeting white white supremacist or
when you see him echoing arguments that
were made by white supremacists then you
have to ask the question about what kind
of shifts in our political culture are
underway I think that they're extremely
concerning I think they should be
concerning to all of us I imagine they
are concerning to all of you I think
they're concerning to John as he
acknowledged so I don't think we're
talking about something that is isolated
I think we're talking about something
that is reanimated and I do agree also
with John that I don't think most
Americans are walking around with
deep-seated racial animus that is kind
of that is kind of enlivening them all
the time but I do think a substantial
number are and I strongly disagree with
the idea that that animus is somehow
fundamentally changed I mean it's
interesting in the rebuttal to me that
John kind of wants to have it both ways
he wants to say that anti-racists are so
obsessed with motivation and inner
psychology that they're not seeing
what's actually being done to people but
then he turns around and says voter
suppression in Georgia is not really
motivated by the same thing it's
actually it's actually sort of you know
coming from some different place they
just don't they just want to get the
votes well why do they want to get the
votes they want to get the votes because
they want to continue to create certain
kinds of conditions which produce and
rely on
both racial and economic inequality and
I strongly agree with John that we
cannot be separating if this is what I
understand him to be saying issues of
racial and economic inequality we have
to be talking about them together I'm
not that interested in converting people
from their inner held racist thoughts
I'm interested in them stop stopping
acting in racist ways and the burden of
my remarks today was to suggest that we
live in a society where more and more
people are being emboldened to act in
racist ways in our political process in
the streets and that and and that both
of those things connect to and build
upon the fact that we continue to have a
society that is divided and unequal in
racist in racial terms and those
inherited racial inequalities do come
from a deep past that we have never
properly reckoned with in public policy
or in our public history okay so if
that's if that that's what I mean by
anti-racist racism and I am an
anti-racist and I probably will would
and will in our conversation agree with
certain aspects of what John is saying I
don't actually think that a lot of
things that he's saying are are things
that I would strongly take issue with
necessarily I I don't necessarily want
us to trivialize the kind of the kind of
struggles and conflicts and divisions
that we have in our society right now
and I certainly don't want to imagine
and I never have in my work imagined
that African Americans in particular or
some sort of benighted
kind of failed people that can't can't
manage for themselves I've always taken
heart from the great phrase for Malcolm
X which the problem with a segregated
school is not that black people are in
one and white people are in another but
that that nobody cares about the black
school nobody's investing in it nobody's
putting resources into it that's where
we need to
to understand where the rubber meets the
road on racism today so I'm all for that
but to me that's that just goes back to
my last point in my opening remarks we
need a more effective anti racism in
this society we need to actually redress
the histories of racial inequality that
we're still saddled with then maybe
we'll will stop having this conversation
in the same way I'm not sure we'll get
to the promised land because I don't
actually see politics in those terms so
in that sense I think John's arguing not
necessarily with with me but with this
kind of phantom of his own imagination
and I'm not saying it's completely
outside the bounds of what I hear in
universities and from students but I
don't actually take that to be
reflective of what is actually going on
in the world that we live in right now
thank you both
we're gonna be opening up to questions
shortly but I want to line up and first
the as you both know you have the option
of asking the other question at any time
do either of you want to pose a question
to the other at this point
Nikhil what does it mean to redress the
disparities of the past how would we do
that because when I say that there are
things that we uh Terr that seem and I'm
not accusing you of being some sort of
fantasies but when I say that we can
slip into the incantation all what's the
redressing what would what would we do
that we haven't done already and but I
understand that there needs to be
activism on behalf of disenfranchised
black people but redressing the past
what do you mean well this is this is
obviously a huge conversation to open up
so I'll try to give a brief and directed
answer in your remarks you talked in the
beginning about the way in which we see
criminal justice involvement as if it's
somehow an exclusively black issue
specifically black men being killed by
the police and I I think that what
everything that you said in those
opening remarks I could not agree with
you more
I do a lot of work with people in prison
so we get a distorted view of the world
in part when we look at it through an
exclusively racial prism okay we don't
see the scope again of how issues of
race connects to to socio-economic
issues to issues of poverty to issues a
spatial isolation to a whole range of
issues so I'm I'm all on board with that
that kind of argument but I would say
that if you look at the history of the
punitive turn in carceral policy in the
United States that it was sold
politically to Publix through what I'm
calling political racism in other words
it was the figure of you know to go back
to any number of figures the Central
Park five which Donald Trump raised as
as these wild boys should be executed
and even though they were later proved
to be innocent he still didn't
acknowledge that it goes back to the
Willie Horton ad that George HW Bush
used to defeat Michael Dukakis it goes
back to Hillary Clinton's language of
super predators and Ronald Reagan's
language of gangbangers and and so forth
in the drug war right so we have a long
history of politicians using a
racialized discourse to sell us on
punitive policies that have harmed black
communities and harmed poor whites
perhaps we could argue about the
proportionality there but that have been
devastating for our society right so to
me that is an example of how political
racism works how it's been harmful how
it remains harmful so a part of
redressing that would by feet would be
figuring out how we start to undo that
not act that way oppose that and change
the dynamic of how we do our politic you
have identified where we differ now what
you're saying is true and it might
surprise you to hear that yes the war on
drugs and it's actually been made
clearer especially over the past two or
three years had a racial component that
was an anti black policy it was also
something that happened when I was one
now I'm not saying that the past
just the past what you just said is true
but this is 2018 and what I mean by its
2018 is I have cousins in jail I know
the sorts of things that they did and I
know that in most cases they really
shouldn't be in jail what do we do about
it now
and I want to put this carefully but
talking about the Willie Horton ad isn't
gonna get cousin xxx out of jail I think
we need to talk about
for example ending the war on drugs and
not just a little stuff with weed very
important that should be absolutely
crucial to talking about what goes on
with both white and black poor people
especially men because what we're
talking about is something that
eternally tempts underserved men into a
black market and into not getting their
diploma and winding up the kind of
statistics that we're talking about to
me that should be the main thing we
focus on instead of and with all due
respect instead of the there's only one
word the recitation that you just did a
very important and disgusting history
that happened I don't think we can
reverse talking about that and the fact
that it was done by people who were
really shitty we can't we can't fix them
most of them are dead so what do we do
not so one of them's president granted
but what do we what do we do now
that's my question well you know III
hundred percent agree with you and the
war on drugs I mean we we could have a
policy discussion of what needs to be
done and I would say and the drill and
the war on drugs would be at the
forefront I think what happened in in
Florida with the ending with the ending
of felon disfranchisement amendment for
was was a magnificent thing you know and
that was that was won by voting rights
activists working for years in that
state I think that's something kind of
thing that we have to we have to pursue
across the board I started a prison
education program at NYU where we go
back into prisons and jails with other
other colleges have done and tried to
provide education for people in prison
so that when they come out of prison
they have opportunities all the prison
education programs got wiped out in the
1990s with the crime bill which is not
that long ago the problem is when I
rehearse the litany it's not because
it's a catechism to me it's because it's
accumulative history that repeats itself
that gets reinstated if it gets
reconstituted by new policymakers and
ambitious and unscrupulous politicians
who want to manipulate us in these kinds
of ways and we now have one of them in
the White House that's using a different
set of racial codes and racial fears to
make us think that like our major
problem is immigrants coming across the
border now now you know that's why I
would talk in those terms but I'm
certainly not averse to having the kind
of policy discussion about what needs to
be done and I think my own view and my
own practice is to think very much in
those terms so so here one more thing
and then I have one for you okay how far
do you think we can get in teaching
people not to be racist because my
personal feeling especially after 2016
is that we've hit a wall there and that
in terms of making life better for
people left behind who can't help
themselves telling the Americans who are
left to a racist and it's not just a few
telling them stop that it's not gonna
work it was one thing to say in the 50s
and 60s give black people the right to
vote to work as a lawyer to eat where
you eat it was one thing to say in 1968
Fair Housing Act black people can live
where you live and then it was another
thing to say through Norman Lear sitcoms
and general shaming don't be a bigot I'm
not sure that we can come any further
and it seems to me that if we're talking
about people carrying torches in
charlottesville they're beyond reason
and so whatever we're gonna do I'm
inclined to do it without I'm sure
you'll understand that it is a kind of
preaching that kind of preaching simply
because I don't see how it works anymore
you may know something I don't about the
efficacy of it I don't disagree with you
I don't think shame works I think we're
at a political culture that thrives on
shaming that thrives on the kind of free
zone of shame I think as I said before a
part of the
the right-wing strategy right now to
kind of move the Overton Window is to
take things that were forbidden to make
them fringe and then make the mainstream
the fact that I think we even start to
frame debates in the ways that we're
framing them tonight seems to me to be
slightly part of that I mean I wish
anti-racism were a civil religion in the
United States as you suggested I I think
mmm it was in some ways I don't think it
is actually quite quite so right now but
no I don't I don't believe that we can
necessarily convinced racists through
through reason or through shame I think
we have to crush them politically and
and I think that that's gonna come
through organization it's gonna come
through education it's cut it's gonna
come through people understanding the
kind of like high-tech Jim Crow
maneuvers that are going on in Georgia
which I don't think are available or
well understood by most people I think
it's gonna it's gonna come by in certain
in certain moments through through
presenting a very strong principled
stand where we don't allow ourselves to
be cowed in certain ways there are lots
of there are lots of methods I think for
approaching the problem but I I do agree
with you I don't think yelling and
shouting at people and calling them
racist is going to work and then the
last thing I would say is that as I said
in my remarks I don't ultimately care a
hundred percent
someone is racist I mean we have a big
conversation about the white
working-class right now and whether
people have racist attitudes ppthere
people everything they do it there are
people of racist attitudes and they're
people have racist attitudes who are led
in various ways to vote against what may
be their economic interests and I
believe that we have to convince people
to vote for their interests and vote in
the right ways and that might mean that
might mean that they then enter into a
coalition with people that they have
racist attitudes towards and when they
enter into that coalition of people with
racist attitudes and we see this through
the history of the labor movement
sometimes those racist attitudes start
to change the only way they really start
to change is if people actually are
working together towards concrete ends
they don't start to change by people
hectoring each other and calling each
other names so I'm on board
and the concrete ends I think would be
more important than how the Archie
Bunker feels ultimately I ready I agree
I agree so John let me ask you I read
your article you know about anti racism
as a civil religion and you know I
thought it was measured and I thought it
was smart and you know but I wonder you
know you wrote that and published it in
2015 so we're here in 2017 2018 2018
sorry not shows remind mind this I I
have I have small children that's my
excuse
time stands still so what would you what
would you change in your has has any of
your own thinking changed since you
wrote that article in 2015 no not a word
no I I wrote that article knowing full
well that there are a lot of racist
people in this country I was not as
completely surprised by the election of
Donald Trump as many people were I think
that most of the people who voted for
him are not what I would call a racist
they just don't consider racism a
priority and many people would consider
it the same thing no life sucks I that
didn't surprise me now that article
actually is one of the few that I
actually sometimes reread and I think
wow that nothing has changed I believe
that um black America would benefit from
a roughly four or five plank platform
that could happen and in which black
people could thrive regardless of how
Donald Trump or anybody who voted for
him fell and I think frankly most black
people of all stations in life don't
care that much how white people feel but
I think an awful lot can happen and we
start losing imagination I'm hearing it
from you when you're talking about these
coalition's within which racism might
exist but that's not something that we
usually talk about there's this sense
that the main meal must be combating the
feelings that people have out of a
certain one idea that once those
feelings go away that life will then be
able to get better for a black person in
a housing project I don't think that
Bayard Rustin and Roger Wilkins and
Martin Luther King or even Malcolm X
thought that way
I think that it's something that settled
in for us moderns and I'd like to get
away from it because I think that great
things really good things can happen for
the black community despite the fact
that we will live in an imperfect nation
which will always be riven by racism I
think I said that at the end of the
article that you're talking about that
there can be a platform or maybe it was
the article I wrote after that I don't
think now violence is a hideous thing
I'm not minimizing that but I don't
think racist attitudes are as important
as we're often told mainly because I
don't think we can do anything about
them yeah I guess I'll have one last
sort of sort of crack of this so you
know one of the things that that kind of
disturbed me a little bit about your
piece in 2015 was that sort of the the
resonances it has and I I don't I don't
think this is any of this is intentional
on your part and I I'm not accusing you
of anything I want to just be clear
about that I even hesitated to bring
this up but in the European far-right
right now you you see this argument from
people like Guillaume Fey and Daniel
Freiburg that anti racism is a
totalitarian religious ideology I
thought that's the that's the framing
they use Frei Fey writes the touchstone
of the self-righteous anti racism is the
most advanced expression of postmodern
totalitarian ideology so this is a kind
of a far-right meme kind of like
cultural Marxism these days and there's
one line in your and your essay that
troubled me where you say anti racism is
a flawed religion that quote pollutes
our racial dialogue and and that word
pollution bothered me and I know you're
a linguist and I know you're
linguistically sensitive and I even
hesitate to argue with you on these on
this train
knowing how clever you are but but the
but the language but the length but the
language of pollution I think to my way
of thinking you know and
the way it's connected to to an idea of
anti-racism as some kind of as I've said
a kind of phantom that sweeps over this
conversation we moderns have this kind
of psychologists sticks or tough sort of
obsession with race or something it
strikes me a little bit like like it's
it's it's kind of something made up you
know I see elements of it sometimes in
my students but I see it as a sign of
their youth their desire for purity
politics and so forth and it's not
confined to race it it runs the gamut of
other things as far as psychologism goes
it's rife throughout American society
right we're always talking about self
help and betterment and being better
people and were preoccupied with sin and
guilt and all this kind of stuff but to
sort of focus on anti racism as
something that is polluting our dialogue
at this moment seems to me to be a sort
of a dangerous a kind of a dangerous way
of going about talking about this issue
which is one of the reasons why I really
pulled back to kind of say what is
racism today we have structural racism
we have political racism and we have
racist violence that's what racism is
that's what we need to oppose to me anti
racism is opposition to racism so so I I
haven't accepted your terms for this
argument in a sense right we've but but
I actually think there are lines of
agreement I know we're supposed to fight
and we're supposed to try to win you
know one side or the other but I
actually think that that then I don't
accept the framing that you've given to
this you know and I've sort of offered a
different framing is there anything in
my framing and this is why I asked you
the question if your thinking has
changed at all in the last two years
that might make you want to reconsider
at all the the kind of way in which
certain arguments are now deployed in in
the right-wing sort of sort of sort of
Ethernet whatever it is and the way
they're circulating there's always a
danger of that kind of misinterpretation
when you write something and you're
trying to make a strong argument and
there's a certain point at which I I
don't mean to sound flippant but I can't
be concerned with how
an Austrian politician might interpret
something that I write in The Daily
Beast but I think frankly that you and I
have a very different sense of the
prevalence of this religion I very much
think that it is the civil religion of
let me clarify not America in general I
mean blue America I mean educated
America and educated America has a
certain influence now step beyond that
certainly this kind of anti racism
starts tottering severely we've seen
that and who has become president but in
terms of we of the chattering classes
who have an awful lot of power I think
that it is much more than the occasional
hot-headed undergraduate it starts there
but it's also true in terms of faculty
and hirings and the way graduate
students are treated I think with this
audience I don't even need to recount
basically all you have to do is open up
quill at and you will see all of these
things described these are real things
it has affected my own academic career
and remember I'm not a social scientist
I just play one on TV
I'm the linguist and these sorts of
things have been real for a while and
have really crested since 2013 and I
find that they really do here's a quick
example um suppose there's a book by a
leading black thinker that basically
expresses an extremely anti white
viewpoint right down to saying that this
person has children he sees them playing
here in New York with white kids at his
elementary school and is afraid because
he doesn't he's afraid that his child
doesn't understand what white people are
capable of and let's say the book is
full of things like that and it's clear
that this person really doesn't like
white people very much and this person's
book is assigned for white people of our
world to read all over the country and
let's say that someone like me has white
friends who for example come to his
house from a reading group where
everybody had to read that book which
basically says that it's okay to be a
very brilliant black person and to
exhibit spontaneous hostile aunt
animus and elevate it as serious thought
and you can see in that white person's
eyes that she understands that what that
book said is not something that she
fully agrees with she doesn't think that
her children are worth being thought of
that way that she's worth being thought
of in the ways that this book portrays
her but her answer is I'm not supposed
to judge how do I know how he feels and
so I thought it was wonderful well for
one thing that's a polluted dialogue
because one its incoherent it doesn't
really make sense and to that person who
was one of the nicest people in the
world is unintentionally being
condescending she's not requiring of
that author the rigor that she would
require of frankly a white author of a
Jonathan Franzen of a Steve Pinker and
therefore by extension its condescending
to me yes it's partly about me that's
the sort of thing that we're seeing it's
not just the occasional undergraduate
who breaks something in the cafeteria
and complains about Vietnamese food that
isn't authentic this is this is big and
you and I live in the same world and I
think it's interesting that we perceive
this differently but I want to make it
clear that I do think that in our world
it is a dominant religion and part of
the way we know it is that just like
medievals we don't know it's a religion
we don't think about it
the medievals didn't say they were
religious it was just the way the world
was thought to be that's where we are
now yeah okay I want to take moderators
privacy to ask two questions of you and
then and then with the audience question
for John McWhorter the Nikhil was at
first reviewing what I think he called
structural racism he went over a series
of statements about how more difficult
to get a job if you're black
difficult to get decent housing
basically portrayed a situation in which
there there is a pattern of racism
against Blacks with respect to housing
jobs and so on do did you accept his
characterization or do you challenge it
in any important way I don't want to
over talk because I just did but no I
don't challenge the
things everything that I'm saying is
said within a context of knowing that
there are those disparities some of them
are more complicated than we're often
told but not enough to matter yeah these
disparities due to racism you think one
can say that okay okay questions of
infinite kill John mentioned two or
three very specific four or five
actually specific examples of anti
racism that he felt are very harmful the
reason when he mentioned just mentioned
a couple of them was for example that
that it's regarded as racist to
discipline black kids and schools who
create turmoil and that that that holds
everybody back he mentioned that that
there's there's this far less concern
about the danger from black gangs toward
black people the much greater
possibility that chance of getting
killed by another black president than
by a white cop then the third thing you
mentioned for example was that that
affirmative action makes it hard for
black kids to function in schools where
they're overqualified could you do you
regard those three things for example as
bad examples of anti racism that should
be stopped well I speak to them all in
turn let me just say that I can see how
affirmative action can produce
stereotype threat what the psychologist
Claude Steele has called the stereotype
threat and I can see how it could work
to produce a kind of stigma among the
recipient and that might not be a
positive thing but that's also because
we have not actually understood
necessarily how difficult it might be
for somebody coming from a certain place
to get to a certain place right so so so
the the the problem of racism from my
standpoint is is is actually in many
ways encapsulated by the ways in which
it's been characterized by this side of
the debate which is like we all know
that well if we all knew that if we all
knew these things if we all knew the
depth of
discrimination of its persistence then
why have we not been able to produce the
kind of public policy to address it I
don't think the reason for that is anti
racism actually I think the reason for
that is that there hasn't been the
public will and interest in addressing
that and then actually our public
policies have been turned towards racist
ends and as in the carceral turn and
John you know points to the the example
of de Blasio and punishing black boys
and to me that's actually an outlier I
don't think that that's actually what
happens in most parts of the country in
most schools where african-american
children are being disciplined and where
we have something that we know quite
well there's a school to Prison Pipeline
there's tons of research on this many
many urban schools now have police in
the schools where if there's an
infraction that people are actually
immediately put into a situation of
potential criminal punishment
particularly african-american children
so I think it's it's it's misleading
actually that example and then I guess
the last thing I want to say and it sort
of comes back to the the the longer set
of remarks that John was making I can
completely see how it would be a problem
to feel condescended to you know and I
could completely see how people not
being truthful and not feeling like I
can speak openly and actually debate
things does let's say I wouldn't use the
word pollute distort distort disturb
undermine our dialogue but once again
once again I feel like you're you are
actually talking about feelings you're
talking about your feelings you're
talking about the negative feelings that
might be that might produce in a kind of
in a kind of elite a space of the
cocktail party of their dinner party or
the academic department you're actually
not addressing what I think is a much
more significant harm that is being done
to people by the ways in which existing
and ongoing racial disparities racist
demagoguery and racializing public
policy actually works in our society so
I would much
rather us be talking about those things
I think if we were actually talking
about those things rather than just
saying oh we all know that you know then
we actually might have a different
conversation we might actually have a
different kind of anti-racism
let's try this and the war on drugs make
sure that all poor women have
long-acting reproductive contraception
available to them at no or little charge
make sure that any child below a certain
income level is taught to read via
phonics rather than by the whole word
method I know that sounds wonky that is
huge but because it's kind of undramatic
and it doesn't have the air of
anti-racism about it nobody really wants
to talk about it then cherish and
support vocational training get rid of
the idea that to be a human being you
have to go to four years of school where
you pretend to enjoy Shakespeare very
important I know so many young black men
who are electricians or you know
repairman making more money that I made
until rather late in my life that should
be taught now that should be emphasized
now if you did just those four things we
would be in a new world instead let's
imagine that there's a very artfully
written article about how we need to
once again call for reparations written
as if reparations hadn't been discussed
to death around the turn of the
millennium and thought of by people from
all sides of the political spectrum as
an unfeasible idea partly because you
could say that there have already been
reparations but the idea is so
incoherent John the taught Donaghy C
Coates is not stopping your ideas from
emerging it's the GOP Congress it's the
Democratic Party I disagree it's it's
the political system that we know that
has the party duopoly and the ways in
which it is work to actually prevent but
public policies work that would actually
address systemic economic inequality in
a serious way it is it is it is a
phantom that you're producing you know
it's not can you really can you really
tell me that there's any of
that if the Democrats were in power that
the four things that I talked about or
even three or even two would actually be
given serious consideration and remember
I remember it's not just me I'm not
making this up these are things that I'm
getting from people who know what
they're talking hundred percent agree
with you if the Democrats were empowered
those things won't won't won't happen
which is why we need to actually
transform the Democratic Party we need
to make the Democratic Party a genuine
social democratic party it would agree
with so so you know when and if that
happens we may have the I mean I'll come
back for the socialism debate next time
but you know if we have something like
that happened then we we will have a
different kind of political I'm not I'm
not pinning my hopes on the Democratic
Party either I just don't think that the
problems that are sort of as they are
identified by coalesce or as they're
sort of pinned on some kind of some kind
of narrow band of academic discussion
are actually even touching most of
what's happening on the ground where
people live how people are suffering how
people are striving IIIi I'm a hundred
percent with you that we should be doing
those things and but I don't think anti
racism is the thing that's causing the
harm I think the things that are causing
the harm are many of the things that
have long caused the harm right which is
a kind of variety as I laid out of of
racist and classist structures within
our society that have produced disparity
that have produced premature death that
have produced over incarceration and
that have produced the kind of civil
conflict that we now experience so your
your claim is that the Intelligencia of
our nation have no particular or
interesting effect on what sorts of
policies are talked about and eventually
not at all not at all not at all the
economics profession has an enormous
impact I don't think the economics but
apparently not high-profile magaz no no
the economic profession in general I
don't think gives a [ __ ] about
reparations or Tana hasty coats I think
most of political science doesn't care a
little bit about it not one bit I don't
think you'd find it in the Wall Street
Journal I don't think you'd find it in
Baron
I don't think you'd find it in the
financial times I mean you may have a
the odd review here or there but that is
not the discourse that is ruling the
world the discourse that's ruling the
world is the discourse of money and
finance and austerity and the room and
the sort of limitations that are going
to be placed on governmental
intervention very little of it is
actually addressing issues of race and
racial disparity you guys have been
great they've been an extended debate
between the two guys which I think we
must weave very much appreciated I do
want to give it make it open to audience
questions somebody in the audience I
don't see the mic somebody at the mic
want to ask the first question you know
oh it's over there my god okay please
make it a question and not a statement
go ahead yes okay a great discussion
thus for our gentlemen I I know that
that's a statement question I know Gina
joy wait Gina enjoys brevity I
understand but I'm standing in front of
John McWhorter who I've loved your work
for so long your conversations with
Glenn Lowry are indispensable for
anybody who cares about race Thank You
Nakia I look forward to pouring into
your work further a question about their
discussion about race in general
obviously in this room it's of a very
high level with you two gentlemen my
question is the wider race discussion
outside of this data outside of Soho
forum has it hit a wall does it need to
be redirected is it stuck because I find
so much of it are not people who care
about actual policy prescriptions but
people who are performative who are
arguing things on a surface level we've
mentioned the drug war here drug war is
important I don't know why people are
yelling about it every day instead we're
talking about how Trump talks to
reporters it's in like substance so I'm
just wondering you know how do we get
out of we're at now to a wider or more
substantive discussion and I know that
might that's a tall order but if anybody
can do it you know you guys can well I
think that one way that we could make it
more substantive because I don't think
that it is is I mean apparently the
intelligentsia
doesn't matter but what I said it's
somebody who tries to pretend to be part
of it I think that this America should
become more aware that there is a
difference between having a religion and
being interested in political activism
such that it becomes less important
what's the latest racist thing that
Donald Trump said you know it's real
it's hard being a writer in these times
because my general thought is yes I know
and he was a racist since before he was
president he's gonna keep saying those
things because he's mentally ten and
that's what he does and so there's
nothing interesting about it yes we
should be talking about the war on drugs
I think that with all due respect to
Nikhil's view I think a lot of the
reasons that we talk more about what
Trump says about Omarosa although
there's also a sexist issue there too
rather than what would help somebody
like someone's cousin who is unjustly in
prison it's because we're dealing with I
hate using this very punitive word but
virtue signaling now stands in for being
politically concerned a person who in
1965 would have said what can I do to
help is now asking how can I show that
I'm a moral person but that's more
Martin Luther than Martin Luther King I
just made that up just now there again
as I knew I was facing a very clever
opponent let me just say that was really
sponte let me just say that it if I have
virtue signaled once tonight I will I
will do a Mia culpa that is not my
purpose I am a full believer in
practical political activity that is
what we need to be doing so I agree with
John in many respects on this question
but when we talk about Trump's words and
Trump's actions we're not talking about
Omarosa this is just another example of
a kind of trivialization Trump right
during the election talked about issuing
an executive order to end birthright
citizenship now none of us necessarily
think he can do that legally but there
are actually constitutional scholars who
disagree on the question of whether
birthright citizenship is mandated under
the 14th amendment it's a serious
serious debate and it's going to hinge
the juridical parsing of forwards right
under the jurisdiction of you know which
are meant to apply to people who are
born here if you're born under the
jurisdiction of your birthright citizen
but our people who come here illegally
or without papers in an authorized way
are they under the jurisdiction of
United
this is gonna be potentially a subject
to debate it's going to be a subject
that is going to open up potential
possibility of stripping citizenship
from from hundreds of thousands of
people now am I just being alarmist
have you seen okay perhaps you think so
you think I'm being alarmist that's
that's good I'm glad to have that out on
the table because I personally don't
think it's alarmist I don't think it's
an alarmist in a country that has
engaged in family separation at the
border in a country that is engaged in
torture during the Iraq war in a country
that has launched wars in the Middle
East under false pretenses that have
killed hundreds of thousands of people
you're not you know you're not really
supposed to heckle in this environment
but the fact that you are is indicative
to me that you actually are not willing
to have a reasoned debate about this so
the point is that we have a situation
where we are dealing with someone who is
actually engaging in in attacks that are
racially inflected and and framed that
involve parts of the population and
making them extremely vulnerable so the
idea that you want to trivialize it and
make it something that we should just
kind of ignore or laugh off or say oh
that's just Donald Trump being Donald
Trump to me is sort of just kind of
proving my point next question hi there
my worries about blowback given that
white America is still the majority of
the u.s. population and that runs the
gamut economically what does that mean
for the current state of anti racism of
white guilt and white privilege where
you have people who are neither
we'll definitely aren't privileged are
you laying a fertile ground for new
races in the coming future am i laying
the fertile ground is the current
situation of anti the religious
situation of anti racism Lane a fertile
ground for the next generation of racist
so should I take that first well I
thought he was talking sin to you but I
I say well something well why don't you
take the question John
I just talked for the Lord okay um the
truth is that if that kind of reasoning
that kind of anti-racist reasoning is
aired and aimed and a lot of it does
involve abusing and making fun of and
being condescending towards a certain
kind of person who's viewed as and often
is less enlightened then it certainly is
not a recipe for polity and I don't see
why it would not stir up a degree of
racism now once again for me and it's
not that I'm trivializing it Nikhil and
I don't think it's funny but I think to
an extent that kind of racism is always
gonna be there and so for example now
this is where I think just people will
differ Trump is definitely creating an
environment where people are being more
open about feelings that probably 10
years ago they would keep more to
themselves he's basically winking and
saying that they're things that are okay
including violence which is particularly
frightening but just in general he is
creating this idea that it's okay to be
Archie Bunker my feeling really is that
I would rather have it out in the open
then have the people keeping it quiet
and being polite and mumbling when my
back is turned I'd rather know what
they're saying I can see how maybe you
might feel that progress would be if
they maybe we know that they're not
going we can't make them not have the
feeling but at least they won't say it
that it would be better if there was a
kind of a politeness I kind of want them
to say it so I know who to avoid and
just because I feel like I'm living in
there's kind of a blue pill red pill
aspect to it for me I want to know what
we're
I'm actually living in so things will
differ I don't know if we're talking
about a racist onslaught however I don't
think that anti racism is dangerous in
that it's gonna create charlottesville
Trump is more responsible for things
like that yeah America may I just jump
in and ask for clarification about the
role of the intelligentsia would you
agree to kill that Tunisia Coates writes
bestsellers MacArthur Genius a lot of
writers spawned by him influences the
media would you agree that they play a
role in influencing voter attitudes and
that voter attitudes then play a role at
the bat the when they vote and also
influence politicians so that it's not
just you know the the moneyed classes
that the intelligentsia clearly is an
important force in the sense that I
described would you agree with that yes
okay if that's the case then would you
agree then that Chinese eCos if he's
saying are what's really on the agenda
is reparations what's really on the
agenda is understanding as tiny heezy
Coates wrote I had no sympathy for the
white firefighters who died in the World
Trade Center because they're white
that's what he wrote in his best-selling
book would you agree that that that's
poisonous and that's out there would you
think that's an influence I'm not gonna
comment on Tana he sees well he's run
writings one way or another well he's a
do I agree with every I'll say this do I
agree with everything in Tana he sees
his influence his influence his
influence I think his influence is is he
has an influence but I would say if his
influence is his influence is does he
have the outside significance that some
would attribute to him I think he's
become a magnet for for all kinds of
criticisms that really his work doesn't
really bear up - he's not he's not a
he's not a serious and deep historian
you know he's somebody who has has done
he writes beautifully he writes well he
writes polemically and and cleverly and
he's been he's been influential but I
don't think his influential is actually
shaping the public debate to the to the
extent to which he may be being sort of
assumed here so that would be by
response
question for the audience well I suppose
I have a single question that all split
between the two of you I believe it was
to paraphrase Aristotle virtue exisiting
means between two vices and any virtuous
behavior can be taken to a realm of
excess where it inevitably becomes a
vice for mister McWhorter where
specifically do you see the vices in the
current movement of anti-racism and for
mr. saying like what would you what
would you need to see for you to view of
the current circumstance as a oh sorry
what would you need to see for you to
view the motion of this debate as a
credible applica
assertion for giving okay the vice of
the modern civic religion which is
anti-racism
is that it's inwardly focused it is an
understandable but dangerous search for
moral absolution
based on what begins as a concern for
people who need help but it ends up
being something that's self-centered
it's about the self it has a
manifestation with black people as well
where there is a sense that we can
consider our roles to be to show white
America that racism exists and I think
that there's a tendency I think most of
us are familiar with this to an extent
there's a certain attraction in painting
yourself as someone who is a survivor of
DeLeon's lots of racism if you're sweet
seeking for a sense of self definition
if you're seeking for a sense of self
validation and all of us as human beings
do if you're a black American in the
United States since about 1970 one way
that you can find that is to think of
yourself as somebody who is a survivor
of this onslaught and so you end up
being a kind of deacon within this
religion there's a whole different issue
of what role black people have in it and
so that's a problem for the simple
reason that when it's all about the self
and all of this signaling it ends up
deflecting from concentrating the way
people
at fifty and sixty years ago on on the
ground policy being woke too often these
days it's just a matter of turning and
doing high fives with people who think
like you and not being concerned with
doing the work and thinking about what
really helps people the overlap between
that woke feeling and effective activism
is only partial and we're losing that
that's the vice for me I think John got
a chance to do his summation
do you you had a tough question they
kill the question was what would have to
be true for you to agree with John about
the resolution that I think that was the
question put you a tough question maybe
you want to duck it that would be okay
what would have to be true for me to
agree with John ah I I think I would
have to think that John was really
identifying something that was in the
way of doing the concrete work that he
says we need to do but actually spends
more time talking about the problems of
anti racism so to me if we were gonna
actually do the work and I do spend a
lot of time doing the work of trying to
help people and do concrete social
change work where I don't think
foregrounding anti-racist commitments is
the important thing to do I totally
agree with that
but when I find puzzling in this kind of
quit like discourse and I think John
John mentioned quill that is is it
there's a kind of a kind of desire to
always find these moments where you know
there's some egregious instance of
political correctness that is preventing
someone from like speaking what's really
on their mind some usually quite well
off and well-placed person from speaking
what's on their mind and that this is
the thing that we should be worried
about because this is the thing that's
in the way of like making the world
better but I don't see any of these
people actually doing any kind of
serious concrete work so it all to me
seems a little bit like up here and a
lot of the kind of examples are
counterfactuals you know what if this
happened or what if that happened well
I've tried to talk about what
is happening and I've tried to identify
it and it's happening in Georgia right
now it's happening in the white house
it's happening in our policies it's
happening in churches and synagogues
where people have been murdered and you
know this is this is the world we're in
and we can choose to kind of continue to
spin out this kind of fake conversation
or we can deal with it I think I'm
hearing summations from both sides
unfortunately we've gone over time way
with the questions
you'll get a chance to the guys are
gonna stick around and over over a glass
of wine they can talk to you about your
questions but you wanna make what you
you you your summation starts oh yes no
no no a skivvy oh no no no sorry no I
was just jokingly saying you're doing
the summations well Martin Luther and
Martin Luther King you you at least one
the the word game tonight you know what
my summation here is I've made my points
I do think that anti racism is important
I do think that what the intelligentsia
chooses as the terms of the discussion
does have an effect on the progress of
history and the progress of a people
that's the way history has always worked
that's certainly the way social history
has worked in the United States at least
until about five minutes ago I see no
reason why it would change now but I
want to say one thing in response to
Nikhil what you said these hypotheticals
that you're mentioning I understand that
strategy of argumentation but I think
that from the beginning my first
statement and with everything else I
said I have talked about concrete events
I have listed them I have given names I
have given figures I have talked about
articles that describe things that are
happening right here in the real America
I have most certainly not recited a
bunch of hypotheticals thank you
well this has been fun
so I'll just I'll just say what I what
I've said and I'll be is try to be as
brief as John so so what John calls
anti-racism and sees as a problem in my
way of thinking is mostly a phantom I
deal with it I deal with it in my
classes you know I had a whole class
last year where I read the N word
because Dubois said it in a passage and
my students felt triggered by it and
they made me stop and they said you
can't say that word you know you're not
a black person and I said why would it
matter if I was a black person and said
that and I had a conversation with them
now do I do I want to go and say they're
being triggered is just about them being
self-obsessed self-absorbed babies no
well yeah exactly
that's what you might say because you
might not actually be interested in
having a constructive dialogue with them
but I'm their teacher so I do have an
interest in having a constructive
dialogue okay now I've suggested that
persisting racial disparities in
economic life in our criminal justice
system underwritten by our underwritten
by active and ongoing racial
discrimination I've suggested that
there's been a resurgence of political
racism and racially motivated voter
suppression that now puts our democracy
at risk and last I've suggested that the
dangerous siren songs of race war and
racist violence have moved from
right-wing fringes of Stormfront and gab
and the Daily Caller to the Twitter deck
of the US president all of this should
be cause for alarm all of this suggests
that racism is currently more harmful
than anti racism and I'll be very
curious to see how you all vote thank
you
well we're opening up the final vote and
just want to take the opportunity to
thank both sides for a very civil and
very spirited exchange certainly you
both created an example for us all to
discuss these of these issues of passion
in a civil fashion and to share your
differences civilly and courteously with
each other so I I commend you both on
that and thank you both for that and I
while you're considering the vote I want
to invite you all to come to our
December 3rd debate we're gonna switch
back to cash to money
Harvard professor of economics Ken
Rogoff author of the curse of cash will
defend the resolution governments of the
advanced industrial economies should
phase out the use of paper money in the
form of large denomination notes and
sharply restrict the use of crypto
currencies
arguing for the negative will be George
Mason University professor of economics
Lawrence white on Monday Jan 14th we
will have a debate that might interest
our two debaters on the subject of
housing
Richard Rothstein Economic Policy
Institute research associate author of
the color of law will defend the
resolution since the federal government
for stirred housing segregation in the
20th century the government should
foster housing integration in the 21st
taking the negative will be Manhattan
Institute senior fellow Howard Hasakah
and on February 22nd February 20th John
Allison a former CEO of the Cato
Institute and a former CEO a BB&T Bank
author of the financial crisis and the
free market cure will defend a
resolution about the causes of the
national crisis how are we doing on the
voting Jane at this point okay
okay well looks like we have the results
recognize that how people vote initially
has a lot to do with how they felt in
the first place voting voting YES on the
resolution 41.5% initially voted yes and
that rose to fifty four point three
percent and so the yes resolution picked
up nearly 13 percentage points that's
what there is to beat and the nose went
from fifteen to twenty nine twenty-eight
percentage point and there's the
disparity was one percentage point you
picked up a little less than 14
percentage points John picked up a
little less than 13 percentage points
it's practically a statistical error
however technically technically
professor seeing you in the tootsie roll
[Applause]